Il faut en finir purement et simplement avec la chasse.
Euh parce que euh.
On ne peut pas s'amuser euh. Du fait de tuer.
Tuer les animaux, ce n'est pas 1 loisir. Hum.
Et euh. On sait que.
Il y a énormément d'animaux qui sont élevés
pour être lâchés
et pour être tué, ça d'un point de vue éthique,
ce n'est plus
acceptable. En tout cas pour nous, ça n'est pas
et pour 1 majorité de
de la population, ça n'est pas.
Les chasseurs
représentent que 2%, que ça soit en zone rural euh.
Mais aussi en zone urbaine. Donc en fait
très peu euh.
De euh. Personnes dans la population et y a 1 consensus
très majoritaire pour arrêter la chasse,
c'est pratique qui sont
extrêmement préjudiciables aux animaux.